[Musik]
zunächst befreien wir dass sie dazu
bilden wir mit den armen einen offenen
herz kopf unserer brust und führen die
arme langsam nach unten dabei atmen sie
tief aus
[Musik]
diese übung heißt die sonne begrüßen
jetzt teilen wir das meer
dazu nehmen wir wieder die arme vor
unsere brust die handflächen drehen wir
nun langsam nach außen und öffnen die
arme weit
dabei atmete tief und langsam
[Musik]
wir machen da weiter wo man letzte woche
aufklärung
der konsum war die ausgangsposition
unsere erste übung im bayrischen ist ein
klassiker dazu winkel wird in arm an wir
bringen in eine waagerechte position und
führen nun das glas zum munde aber nicht
zu hektisch nicht so schnell nicht dass
man auch noch was verschütten
[Musik]
diese übung heißt das glas austrinken
für die nächste übung nehmen wir das
glas in die linke hand wir heben es hoch
verharren kurz in dieser position und
klopfen und dreimal hörbar an das glas
zu unterstützung noch auffordern
diese übung nimmt man nur wie und jetzt
alle sehr schön
wir kommen nun zur abschließenden uni
fassung zur persönlichsten übung im
bayerisch schicken
diese übung heißt dem wirt danken
umgehen solle ja wunderbar großartig ja
dann hommage wieder für heute wir sehen
uns nächste woche wiederum geht der
branche weiter
[Musik]
t mobile